hallo mein name ist luca und meine
freundin also die hier
fragt einfach nicht jeder auf jeden fall
immer extrem viel langeweile
deswegen habe ich mir gesagt hey kennst
ein paar webseiten paar kleine google
easter eggs die einem so ein bisschen
wenn man langeweile hat die zeit
vertreiben können und dann hat sie mir
einfach mal 20 webseiten geschickt die
wir heute testen werden wir starten
direkt mit dieser hier
hat man nämlich den spirit platte ich
hab mir nämlich ein fit bin den mann im
kreis bringen
man muss es wirklich im kreis drehen
[Musik]
heißt kurz 3259 also schreibt mir gerne
unten die kommentare ob ihr habt
mich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht wir
machen allerdings direkt weiter mit der
nächsten website die sie mir geschickt
hat und zwar dass diese hier
die heißt watching
group.com
und wir genau ob man das meer
und das ist gemacht
die maus quasi den rasen hinter sich her
zieht aber
diejenigen unter euch die englisch
können was ich glaube ich bin ziemlich
wenigen vermutlich war es beiseite ich
glaube ihr wisst worum es hier geht und
zwar kann man dem gras beim wachsen zu
gucken
die heißt ghost punkte
und das ist eine ghost erde oder wie
jetzt ist auf jeden fall die erde
aber warum ist das jetzt in seinem gruß
den kann ich irgendwie mit ihnen
interagieren oder so wenn ich das
irgendwie
verstellt weiß mein pc hast mich einfach
dass die nächste website hätten
dessen katze was ist wenn ich auf mein
gott
dicker warum war das so laut tasse aber
katzen
schädigungen an unterricht die katzen
haben könnte ich ja nicht direkt die
abonnieren und dann machen wir weiter
mit oh mein gott
docs.com da kann ich auf play klicken
und dann
okay wir machen weiter haben und zwar
mit der website to nothing for two
minute da geht es dann wirklich los und
die zeit läuft runter und ihr seht auch
schon wenn ich jetzt einfach mal meine
maus bewegen
habe ich verloren
und er machen wird alle zwei minuten
nichts
dass sie jetzt die nächste website
ich weiß nicht was man hier machen muss
wenn ich hier klicken
ach so
wenn ich hier klicken um die sache nach
vorne
schluckauf ich kann auch die wachen hier
verzieren nicht verzehren sondern
verschieben das heißt was passiert wenn
ich mal alle übereinander mache kommen
dann immer neue hier im hintergrund oder
ist dass nico da kommt immer wieder neue
da es komplett egal wo man könnte hier
mit theoretischer also folgt
kann ich auch sein wird
geht auch
es gibt leute
das paket ich freue mich dass ich auf
einer website quadrate verschieben
könnte sind nicht mehr quadratisch idiot
was anderes abi klausur bogen übrigens
auch aus
jux das hier ist die nächste website und
zwar heißt es pixels fighting punkt
kommen da kann man einfach dabei
zugucken wie pixel gegeneinander kämpfen
ich bin für grünen
bei ihm weiß ich es nicht doch gründet
safe gewinnen oder
braun 40 rechts die mitte aber im grünen
ist links und damit des klos mal wie
droht dann wieder helge braun wieder
kleiner dann wird begrünt wieder ein
bisschen kleiner ist
es ist schwierig es ist ein hart
umkämpfter kampf jetzt gucke jetzt
überdenken grün wird safe gewinnen wird
grün gewinn aber jetzt jeden moment
kommen braun wahrscheinlich wieder um
jacken die grün macht dass ich
sage euch grün oder braun braun anhalt
die flanken der die wichtigen punkte
hier hier hier von einer streuen die die
ganze drei die frage ist auch werden die
pixel neu generiert sind so viele fragen
das interessanteste website bisher
ich glaube das wäre wenn ich ein
unternehmen hätte im wartebereich für
kunden geschäftspartner
riesig auf einem monitor will ich das
machen jeder wird da vorsätze nicht
denken
doch und da kann man auch wetten
abschließen dann mache ich geld mit den
leuten die im wartezimmer warten um mit
mir geld zu verdienen das ist wahnsinnig
freuen unternehmens auf der website
eine million mal
das hier ist die tiny tuba website also
kleine kombi oder was
[Musik]
das sind wie
ich kann nur drauf klicken und dann
kommt
[Musik]
ich liebe diese videos und wie invisible
light your finger around to find jetzt
heiligen behind shouting also müssen
unserem aussehen wiederum herbewegen das
spiel
[Musik]
in dem anderen video
ich weiß was meine freunde und ich muss
ganz ganz leise für das dann halt die
neben
die nächste website heißt ist mein
computer und punkt com und die frage die
sich immer dieser ganze objekt findet
ihr ja schon in der domain denn diese
website beantwortet euch ob das gerät
mit dem er die website aufruft
eingeschaltet ist und
das ist es
logischerweise
denn sonst wäre ich auch nicht
das ist einfach nur wie bisher die das
wort jetzt schreibt dank für diese ist
glaub ich hab zum punkt kommen keine
ahnung was sommerpunkt com ist
bis 4
[Musik]
nur
das ist seine organe
saisontor
[Musik]
die brodelnde mit
danke
danke danke
[Musik]
danke hamburg wie heißt eigentlich die
website hamburg
dreht sich einfach was ich kann mir das
scrollen noch irgendwas klicken aber
wenn ihr mal auf sommer kommen gehen
wollt dann
tut das kommen allerdings auch schon zur
letzten webseite ich euch heute
vorstellen möchte und zwar ist das map
krenn.com
ihr werdet einfach irgendwo von google
maps reingeworfen das ist ja wunderschön
hier
das ist ja voll also okay dass hier
jetzt vielleicht nicht sein hier braucht
jetzt auch nicht ist da noch angehalten
um der piste zucchini und da könnt ihr
einfach klicken und dann seid ihr wieder
einem andern ort
das war es
also ist die kamera ich habe auch die
tage von google maps auto gesehen hatte
ich direkt da vom restaurant tisch
aufgestanden
wahrscheinlich würde ich die zensiert
wegen hässlichkeit diese website ist
quasi einfach geo gestern schlecht weil
man kann nicht sagen wo man sich
befindet es wird einfach wirklich
irgendeinem ort ausgesucht werde ich bin
im dschungel
ich stelle das richtig geil vor hier so
zu wohnen mit der ganzen natur aber
irgendwie auch nicht so geil weil du
halt unfassbar viele mücken hast
wenn du wahrscheinlich der einmal in
state mast sitzen zehn tiger neben die
am esszimmertisch aber ich würde an der
stelle sollte ich mich auch werden wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann geht nach
draußen spielen denn das es besser als
ich meine scheiße anzugucken